Hey, you guys.
Do you-*laughs*
sorry, I could hear Mamrie's mouth.
Okay, I'm ready.
Do you remember the last time we were on the couch?
The couch?
I'm sorry but my mouth is so dry.
Now, I hear my mouth.
What is this?
Hey, guys!
Do you remember the last time we were seated on this couch
doing interviews for the making of Camp Takota?
This is how sex happens.
Let's make another movie!
Okay.
*under breath* 1, 2, 3 *snap*
All: We're throwing a house party!
All: Movie!
And you're invited.
To RSVP, go to dirtythirtymovie.com
and check out all the behind the scenes of the making of the film!
*under breath* 1, 2, 3
Not 'til after my meeting though.
I'm gonna grill.
Gotta fix this roof!
Who wants hot dogs?
Sorry, I only eat fake-meat fake meat.
Can you hear that engine?
Probably not. It's a Prius.
*baby noise*
*record scratch*
Dad's home!
Scatter, scatter, scatter-
Here's your burger.
Don't eat and drive.
Grace: And a big thank you to our friends over at Lionsgate
Grace: who most likely regret the decision of working with us already.
Grace: But too late! It's already on the internet.